premières turbulences l'inscription dans
le paysage orléanais d'un bâtiment en
forme aléatoire ouvert en 2013 il est le
lieu de conservation et d'exposition
d'un fonds exceptionnel consacré à l'
architecture
c'est la troisième grande collection au
monde est la seule sur l'architecte
paris mantes deuxième turbulences
l'expérience et visuel intrigante
ludique est nourri notre imaginaire et
notre conception du paysage bâti à la
croisée entre l'art et l'architecte les
turbulences lui seul le nom du lieu se
visite accompagnée ou non d'un guide
vous découvrez au frac centre une
connexion de projets d'architecturé
expérimentale des projets qui vont donc
pas forcément aboutir à une construction
une réalisation mais qui ont été des
projets qui des années 50 à nos jours
ont remis en question ce quelle
architecture et comment évidemment elle
dialogue avec l'art contemporain une
question fondamentale président aux
collections ou vivrons-nous demain
l'exposition temporaire ville
visionnaire explore de nouveaux modèles
premier volet la conception de la vie
dans les années 60
cette exposition présente une centaine
de projets des années 60 une époque
extrêmement riche pour la question de l'
architecture la question du paysage la
question de l'urbanisme
les projets présentés ici s'interroge
sur les modèles de vie sociale
collective dans le futur dans le
contexte de l'après guerre
l'urbanisation s'accroît rapidement le
modèle industriel prédomine alors
l'architecturé rationnelle les
constructions fonctionnel mais d'autres
besoins sociaux émergent et interroge
c'est vrai qu'après la guerre après le
traumatisme de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
le concept de liberté le concept de
mobilité et l'aspiration au
divertissement est une valeur qui
traverse qui irriguent littéralement le
débat architectural et donc ses
architectes proposent des modèles de vie
futur qui intègrent ce désir de
divertissement de mobilité ces valeurs
montantes sont émerger un concept les
villes spatiale grâce à l'apport des
technologies les villes pourraient
s'organiser autrement pour accompagner
les besoins de mobilité
cette grande vision utopique de la ville
spatiale cette finalement un grand
réseau hyper technologies s'est
développée sur pilotis de façon à
pouvoir dégager le sol de la terre et
permettre aux êtres humains de déplacer
leur habitat leur enveloppe et et tous
les bâtiments qui vont
constitué la société du futur
la fin des années 60 verra la confiance
en la technologie et le progrès
s'effriter l'utopie s'envole et la
protestation investi les projets on voit
émerger une jeune génération
d'architectes qui utilisent le projet
architectural comme un espace de
contestation comme un espace de
formulation d'une critique extrêmement
virulente à l'égard des valeurs de la
société
la deuxième partie de l'exposition met
en scène une vingtaine de projets
urbains de grande échelle pour la
plupart en cours de réalisation le défi
est de repenser et régénérer la ville
devenue mégalopole ainsi l'espace urbain
n'ai plus pensé comme une simple
juxtaposition d'éléments mais comme un
système global hawk ou d'architecte pour
aborder la question du réseau global
vont chercher à lire les spécificités
locales de chaque lieu de chaque culture
de chaque contexte est donc cette
tension entre globale et locale que les
architectes visionnaire des années 60
avait travaillé comme un outil de
lecture du territoire on la retrouve
aujourd'hui
alors quelle démarche stratégique
faut-il adopter la ville se doit d'être
un lieu connectés maîtrisé et en même
temps suffisamment souple pour que les
individus se le réapproprient l'usagé
sans doute une clé de cette
appropriation un exemple le grand paris
imaginé par jean nouvel jean nouvel dans
sa proposition vient requalifier des
poches des laisser des espaces vides on
vient recréer du lien on vient
requalifier par la question du paysage
notamment qui permet devenu de suture et
les espaces par la réflexion sur l'usagé
proprement à proprement parler
de 1950 à aujourd'hui la population
mondiale vivent en ville est passée de
30 à 50% en france trois quarts des
habitants sont urbains alors la ville
sera de plus en plus vécue comme un
monde permanent global autonome aux
fonctions multiples et aux réseaux
complexes des architectures hybrides
verront le jour pour répondre à ces
nouvelles exigences et peut-être trouvé
dans ce nouveau paysage une place pour
l'homme